[Música]
su deportista favorita está muy cerca de
ganar
la multitud contiene el aliento y en el
momento crucial gerra al tiro esa
competidora acaba de experimentar un
fenómeno de bloqueo por el cual una
persona aún después de meses o años de
práctica comete un error justo en el
momento decisivo este bloqueo es común
entre deportistas que a menudo actúan
bajo mucha presión y dependen de
momentos clave pero la ansiedad también
afecta a quienes hablan en público a
participantes en concursos de ortografía
e incluso a músicos famosos
intuitivamente adjudicamos esa ansiedad
a un estado nervioso Pero por qué ese
nerviosismo perjudica el desempeño de
los expertos Existen dos grupos de
teorías que sostienen que el bloqueo
está ligado a la concentración
por un lado están las teorías de
distracción que afirman que el
rendimiento se reciente cuando la mente
se distrae con preocupaciones dudas o
temores en lugar de concentrarse en la
tarea cuando los pensamientos relevantes
e irrelevantes compiten por la misma
atención alguno debe ceder el cerebro
solo puede procesar cierta información a
la vez las tareas que desafían la
memoria de trabajo que es el anotador
mental donde almacenamos números
telefónicos Y listas de compras son muy
vulnerables a la presión en un estudio
en 2004 un grupo de universitarios debió
resolver problemas matemáticos algunos
sencillos y otros complejos de Gran
exigencia para la memoria la mitad de
los estudiantes resolvió ambos tipos de
problemas sin presión alguna en tanto
que los otros lo hicieron en situaciones
de calma y estrés todos resolvieron los
problemas fáciles pero los estresados
tuvieron peor desempeño en los problemas
difíciles con uso de la memoria
las teorías de monitoreo explícito
forman el segundo grupo de explicaciones
explican cómo la presión puede inducir a
la gente analizar por demás la tarea
estas teorías postulan que una vez
automatizada la tarea analizar su
mecanismo preciso interfiere con la
capacidad de realizarla las tareas que
hacemos de manera inconsciente parecen
ser más vulnerables a este tipo de
bloqueo un estudio comparó el desempeño
de golfistas profesionales cuando se
concentraban exclusivamente en invocar
la bola en el ocho respecto de cuando
analizaban de manera exhaustiva las
técnicas de golpe para invocar la bola
por lo general los golfistas hacen estos
movimientos de manera inconsciente por
ello quienes de pronto se pusieron a
examinar los detalles precisos de su
jugada tampoco lograron buenos
resultados y fallaron el tiro los
estudios sugieren que hay individuos más
susceptibles que otros especialmente las
personas tímidas ansiosas y temerosas
del juicio negativo de los demás cómo se
podría evitar el bloqueo en situaciones
importantes primero es bueno practicar
en situaciones de estrés en un estudio
con expertos lanzadores de dardos se
descubrió que Quienes no habían
practicado en situación de estrés tenían
peor desempeño cuando se ponían
nerviosos en segundo lugar hay quienes
aconsejan tener una rutina previa a la
actuación como inspirar repetir alguna
palabra o seguir una secuencia de
movimientos estudios realizados sobre el
golf el juego de bolos y el polo
acuático indican que la práctica de
breves rituales puede inducir un
desempeño más constante y preciso bajo
presión y tercero investigaciones han
demostrado que concentrarse en un
objetivo externo en el momento crucial
da más resultado que enfocarse en un
objetivo interno un estudio con
golfistas reveló que quienes hacían un
golpe corto mientras se concentraban en
la trayectoria de la bola Tenían un
desempeño mejor que Quienes se
concentraban en el movimiento de los
brazos se podría entonces
Modificar el viejo dicho la práctica
bajo estrés con concentración y con ese
glorioso objetivo final en mente hace la
perfección
hay una forma incorrecta de practicar
Cómo puede estar seguro de que está
practicando de una manera que realmente
lo hace mejor en algo descubra los
secretos de la práctica efectiva con
este video